[Music]
Google container registry is a private
container image registry that runs on
Google cloud platforms reliable fast and
secure infrastructure you can access
container registry through secure HTTP
endpoints which allow you to push pull
and manage images from any system VM
instance or your own hardware
additionally you can use the dr.
credential helper command-line tool to
configure docker to authenticate
directly with container registry while
docker provides a central registry for
storing public images you might not want
your images to be accessible to the
world to control access to your images
you must store them in a private
registry this hands-on lab demonstrates
how to build a docker image containing a
basic Python web app and push it to
Google container registry this lab is
also part of a series of labs called
quick starts these labs are designed to
give you a little taste of many features
available with Google Cloud search for
quick starts in the lab catalog to find
the next lab what you'd like to take
next up on our quest is deployment
manager QuickStart
[Music]